hello my name is Nicolas Wagner I am the
Barney
destruction or coach and I'm here to
talk about number bonds which is a an
element of Singapore math that is
vitally important really starts early on
in kindergarten first grade and then
moves and can be used throughout up
through algebra even so today I'm going
to talk about number bonds there's a a a
basic structure to number bonds and what
a number bond is is a decomposition or
breaking a part of numbers in a specific
way that may be helpful so we have whole
we have a whole or the number that
you're decomposing and then we have two
parts and obviously it's not gonna be
just well maybe you're not obviously but
it's not gonna be just a decomposition
of a whole in two parts but you may have
the parts and you're composing the whole
so to give you a specific example we
might have eight which would then be
broken into say five and three and I'll
go over why we why we do this but but I
wanted to emphasize one thing before we
get there number bonds look like this
traditionally however they don't have to
have this structure going back to some
of the research behind Singapore you can
see things in a variety of ways and
that's actually a good thing so you may
see a number bond written sideways or it
may even look a little different
so so don't just familiarize yourself
with this structure but know that there
is a hole with two parts so we're going
to do a few problems to demonstrate why
number bonds are effective they're very
good for developing number sense and a
mental math data I've been emphasizing
in some of my other videos I mean use a
very simple problem to start and then I
will get a little bit more complex to
show you some of the power behind the
number bund so we have 8 plus 6 one
thing that we really emphasize as the
place value part of the place value
conversation is making a 10 emphasize 10
10 is important to our number system we
have a decimal system so making sure
that we are focusing on that 10 in
developing number sense is going to be
is gonna be crucial that being said
let's take this problem and make it into
a simpler one for students they there
are a number of ways that you can do
this and I think actually let me
highlight that
Wow I'm here instead of doing well
actually I'll come back to that we have
4 & 4 might make this problem a little
bit simpler and so you ask why would
that be simpler because now you can
group the 6 and the 4 which the students
will see as 10 and so what we would call
that is making a 10 and so you instead
of having 8 plus 6 which might be a
little bit more daunting the 6 and the 4
might be known and so you would have 4
plus 10 equals 14 again you've been
emphasizing throughout kindergarten and
first grade the idea of a 10 the concept
of a 10
makes it 10 I'll have a page or have a
video rather on on the manipulatives and
how to use manipulatives but one of
those manipulatives is a 10 frame that
looks like this where you're developing
the numbers that make a 10 you're using
manipulatives and working with numbers
up to 10 so they will have a familiarity
instead of with 8 plus 6 they would have
a familiarity of 6 and 4 making a 10
another example of making a 10 it's to
do you compose 6 6 into a 2 & 4 so you
would group the 8 in the 2 w 10 + 4
equals 14 and there would be familiar
with 8 + 2 making a 10 so you're making
it in here you're still making it in
here notice that you can separate either
the first add end or the second a dent I
want what I wanted to highlight a moment
ago was you shouldn't have a hard and
fast rule when talking about how
students simplify problems or break
problems into simpler problems this is
part of the creative process that we
were talking about earlier with
mathematics we want them to be creative
problem-solvers approach problems in a
variety of ways so they don't so they
see the creative side of mathematics but
they also develop further understanding
of some other concepts which you'll see
number of bonds are actually to talk
about one concept they're actually very
good for demonstrating the commutative
property because 6 well it can be 2 & 4
it could also be 4 & 2 & and students
can see that you through the use of
nervous let's do another one
so we're gonna break the eight into a
two and a six now students grow in
comfort with doubles there's there's a
strange ability to attach two doubles
pretty pretty cleanly I don't I say it's
strange because I don't understand fully
why that is but they might see a double
and so they'll recognize that two plus
twelve is then fourteen dimensions math
as a side note dimensions math does not
emphasize doubles because they're not
usable in future and larger numbers is
the I think some of the reasoning behind
that dimensions math I however I
disagree with the the lack of use of
doubles and dimensions math because I do
think that students actually latch on to
them and one of the examples that
dimensions gives is 98 plus 98 some
students might see this and decompose 98
into 90 + 8 + 90 + 8 so they would have
90 plus 90 is 180 plus 8 plus 8 is 16
and so they would have 196 I think that
students might see these doubles and and
know them right away just like they
would know the ninth doubles being 18
let's go ahead and go on to maybe some
of the other operations to give you
examples of other operations it should
be noted that the number of bonds are
used for for addition over basically
decomposing a number into its component
parts not not used for creating a factor
tree for example
let's do 50 1/3 I want you to think for
a second what what numbers what numbers
can I separate 51 into that would make
this problem simpler so I give you just
a second okay
51 could be broken into 30 and 21 now
what makes that simpler 51 is not
something that they would know as a math
fact automatically however 30 divided by
3
the students would recognize as 10 and
21 divided by 3 students would recognize
as 7 so the solution would be 17 and
they might see that much faster than if
they tried to do 51 divided by 3 in long
division form let's do a different one
to show you that not all 50 ones are
going to be the same how would I
how would I do 51 times 8 in a much
simpler way if I tried to break 51 times
8 where I'm breaking the 51 into a 30
and a 21 that doesn't necessarily make
it simpler for a student however if I
decompose 51 into 50 and 1 I now have 50
times 8 or 5 times 8 and add a out of
place value 5 times 50 times 8 would be
400 plus the 1 times 8 should be 8 and
students would see then but that's equal
to 408 so we've done a division done
multiplication let's do a subtraction
problem 51 minus 9
I can break 51 into 40 and 11 or 41 and
10 and then 11 - 9 students would know
as to so I would have 40 plus 2 again I
could have done 51 minus 9 41 and 10 so
then I would have 41 plus 10 minus 9
which would be 1 was equal to 4 you two
while I'm at
well I'm highlighting this one of the
pieces one of the elements that I I
wanted to focus on when I was talking
about the five elements that I look for
in classical math room math class better
saying that is creative problem solving
and so one of the things that I really
want to highlight here is you could have
this problem up here on the board but
the follow up that you should have after
that is did anybody solve it a different
way that allows students to explain
themselves explain how they solved it
differently but the other value is
students can see the creative aspect of
math mics and they can see maybe a new
approach that they didn't know before
and can then solve it more simply if
they like that approach more than they'd
like their own so I mentioned I've done
the OP the the four basic operations I
mentioned that I was going to step it up
a little bit and I think number bonds
the value of number bonds goes beyond
those baek's basic operations with whole
numbers an example will be 5/7 Plus 3/7
students oftentimes this is pretty
straight forward for them they will get
8/7 then the confusion confusion comes
in we have now an improper fraction so I
think instead of jumping straight to the
improper and then having them go to a
mixed
number they can go straight to a mixed
number with with more facility more ease
let me demonstrate that with a number
blonde
instead of making a ten now you are
going to make a one or make a unit so
you can decompose 5/7 into a 1/7 and 4/7
and then you've made it one here so you
have 1/7 plus one is equal to one and
1/7 or alternatively you could have
decomposed the 3/7 to be a 2/7 or in a
1/7 you could have made a single unit or
a 1 here and then had one plus 1/7 which
is one and 1/7
so there is greater ease and I think a
better development of what is actually
taking place what is a fraction it's
referencing a part to a whole it's
coming back to that concept and and
really trying to dig into what happens
beyond the whole once you have more than
what would complete a whole what does
that mean traditionally going from
improper fractions to proper fractions
we would follow this step these steps to
this I'm doing this largely to emphasize
why that what I just showed you was
better to develop the concept of what's
occurring we would take this and when
make it into a long division problem and
we would say how many 7s can go into
I'll talk about language go into is not
exactly right how many how many sevens
divided into
eight I would say one we have one left
over and this is where students really
normally get lost do they say okay I
have one remainder one which that
doesn't mean something to them very well
one our one would not mean something to
them and again you're going to want to
get them to a a mixed number and said
what we asked them to do is to remember
that this goes on top so we have a 1 and
this seven goes here so we have one in
1/7 it's not entirely clear why the one
comes up here and why the 7 goes here or
why you got the 1/7 at all that verse is
having 8/7 decomposed into 7/7 and 1/7
where this is a 1 and that's 1/7 left
over is much clearer much more obvious
what is going on and why you're doing
that now a note on this I I believe that
it's still valuable to teach this method
as long as you're developing the
conceptual side why why is the one here
in the seven here alternatively so this
is going from improper to mixed
let's go from the mixed to the improper
ok so we have 1 and 1/7 one thing that a
lot of teachers will do is they'll teach
a trick it'll teach a trick they say
what I'm gonna do is I take this number
multiply it by this number and then I
add this number some people refer to
this as the popcorn method and let me
explain to you why this works but also
that you should not teach it until after
they have a full development
developmental understanding or a
conceptual understanding of the other
piece let me put the other piece up
first the way that we do want you to
initially teach it 1 and 1/7 is 7/7 and
1/7 because this one is 7/7 it's a hole
here why are we multiplying the 1 times
the 7 because that's the number of units
that would make a hole make a 1 or make
a unit so we would still same idea right
but here we have a trick as opposed to a
concept so 1 times 7 plus plus the 1/7
so this this over here will be 7 7 plus
1/7 I did not complete this 3 8/7 here
we have 1 times 7 is 7 plus 1 all over
the 7 again it's also still 8/7 but this
is clear 1 times 7 plus 1 you're doing
this to get to the the whole number
quantity that would make it to take make
it take a unit form and then adding that
so again this is clear you could teach
this you can teach this but I don't see
you really the need to teach this one
like you wouldn't teach this one sorry
if that was a little unclear but I think
hopefully the value still comes through
you you don't have to stop with
fractions though you can stuck keep keep
going with decimals as well
so for example you could have 30.7 plus
1.5 and I figured I'd do several
examples for you so that you you have
different iterations and different
explanations of number of on C you can
more fully develop that but three plus
0.7 or three and seven tenths if we're
using the correct mathematical language
and one and five tenths you can
decompose 1.5 or one in five tenths into
three tenths and one and two tenths to
make a whole so then you would have four
and one and two tenths to be five and
two tenths could you do it a little
differently
sure so again you would ask at this
point you would ask the question did
anybody solve the problem differently
you want to draw out explanations from
your students I've seen a variety of
ways one of those could be separating
this into three and then seven tenths
and then this into three tents and one
in two tenths making this whole so now
you have three plus one plus one and two
tenths which would be five and two
tenths and there are a variety of ways
to variety of iterations that I'm not
going to necessarily go through I'll do
one more just to belabor the point maybe
a little bit
you can make this into three and two
tenths and five tenths and then you can
make a make a whole number make it into
whole numbers and you have three and two
tenths plus two zero two five and into
tenths okay so let me let me highlight
the reasons why why number ones I've
already talked about it
to a certain extent and that it really
is teaching students to decompose to
break apart problems into simpler
problems let me highlight a few things
first it's the first encounter it gives
the first encounter with the pictorial
okay the first encounter with a
pictorial now when you first introduce
number bonds you will be introducing
them alongside the manipulatives so keep
that in mind that's an important note
when you're introducing number bonds
that's not jumping into this more
abstract thing just right away you have
to teach them that in conjunction with
manipulative use the second point I want
to make it promotes thinking and problem
solving rather than only procedural
fluency so promotes thinking
and problem-solving rather than
rule-following or a reliance on
algorithms it encourages mental math
which we've already discussed is
important because you're not going to
want students to try to approach say a
long division problem if they haven't
learned their multiplication and
subtraction problems and then I've
touched on this it promotes or it
prompts questions like what smaller
questions can I break this down into so
encourages breaking problems into
smaller parts which again I've already
highlighted up but write it up for you
and then all together it really promotes
the number of sense
and normally I put this and this
together but what I mean by number since
here is a deeper understanding of of
numbers and 51 for example was the name
of a quantity which can also be renamed
into 30 and 21 or 50 and one with that I
think you have plenty of examples here
go ahead and check out your dimensions
textbooks if you would like more
examples thank you again for watching
this video